avant ici à chécy il n'y avait que des
vignes à la fin du siècle dernier ont
recensé 200 hectares viticole et en 1890
huit parents d'élèves sur onze étaient
vignerons aujourd'hui il ne reste que
six ou sept viticulteurs à chelsea et
seulement une dizaine d'hectares
cultivés embrasse coûtant par exemple à
87 ans et près de 70 vendanges à son
actif mais il vient de l'annoncer il
prend lui aussi sa retraite et envisage
t'arracher ses vignes rappelle plus
alors il faut bien il ya plus personne
vous voulez faire douter cette personne
tout ça va maintenant j'ai un culte tu
es déjà cherchées pour bourrin christian
quoi tout vient de céder l'exploitation
familiale à son fils il produit du gris
meunier mais lui non plus ne croient pas
de la viticulture pour lui cette
activité n'est pas viable
notre en danger livré à la cave
coopérative
d'autre côté de la loire traversée
orléans et tous et toutes à un circuit
un la vente de vins ça fait de moi j'en
vois bien les les règlements sont de
plus en plus à longueuil et à longue
échéance alors du coup la mairie et
quelques cas siens se mobilisent non pas
pour relancer une économie aléatoire le
vin n'est pas de grande qualité hi la
concurrence est rude mais plutôt pour
entretenir le patrimoine local alors si
la commune achète une vigne
nous aimerions bien que des bénévoles
viennent nous aider à travailler cette
vie je vous répète pour faire revivre ce
passé ce passé viticole de fissy une
association pour la sauvegarde de la
vigne à celle ci doit même prochainement
être constitué mais aujourd'hui le vin
fait désormais partie du folklore